algorithms
you hear about them you know they're
behind your screens
and you may even be here as a result of
one right now
do algorithms amplify our worst human
behaviors
how do algorithms influence your world
views are social media algorithms making
the world
worse i'm going to talk to an ex-youtube
engineer
who built the algorithms that keep us
hooked a former design ethicist from
google
and a professor from oxford who believes
things may not be as bad as we think
they are
but first an experiment to see how what
we feed the algorithm
feeds us in return i'm going to simulate
searching for a video from three
different political perspectives
in order to see how one simple youtube
search influences the algorithm
we'll check a neutral page make three
different profiles
watch the first video that comes up for
each then observe how searches affect
the homepage
and recommendations for control measures
i have three separate laptops
i've cleared the history and the cash on
all of them so we're starting from a
neutral slate
all right so now i'm going to see just
the regular youtube homepage before i've
created anything i see a few different
news videos
a few funny videos ed sheeran some
alabama football
my dog answers fan questions a few
different news clips
and of course the viral tick tock
fleetwood mac video all right so it's
pretty neutral
let's make these profiles okay so now
after i've made my profile
the home page doesn't look too different
it has a little bit of data on me now
because i made that profile but
for the most part the homepage is pretty
similar
looking at this media bias chart i can
see that fox news sways more to the
right
msnbc sways to the left and abc news is
somewhere in the middle
so i'm going to start with my first
simulated political perspective i've
looked at fox news
and i'm going to click on the first
video c-span suspends steve scully after
he missed to line about twitter hack i'm
gonna watch the video
all the way through give it a like let's
make the second profile
okay now i'm gonna simulate the second
political perspective
from msnbc watch all in with chris hayes
highlights watch the video all the way
through
i'm going to give it a like one thing
that's really interesting the
recommended videos
follow the same order for both profiles
but just recommending
the different news stations the first
profile recommended three fox news
videos
and one pbs video the second profile
recommended three
msnbc profiles and one pbs profile
it seems like pbs is considered quite
neutral it's more educational and
academic so if you're going down some
form of a rabbit hole
it's not likely to throw off your search
i think that's something interesting to
note
simulating searching a video from the
third political perspective
abc news spotlight on early voting in
north carolina i'm going to watch the
full video and give it a like
[Music]
now let's see how the home page changed
at the first profile i'm already seeing
a big difference
fox news fox business i see some
favorable videos about president trump
some unfavorable videos about nancy
pelosi i do see a wall street journal
but it's mostly fox channels that are
dominating i do see some
positive videos about amy coney barrett
the supreme court confirmation
i do see some negative videos about
hillary clinton ted talk
inside the mind of a master
procrastinator maybe i should watch that
and a quirky one about president trump's
dance moves
and that's just from one video search i
saw quite a few videos in favor of
president trump quite a few
videos against joe biden a few funny
videos
a few videos about meditation i'm gonna
save for later for the profile where i
searched msnbc
i see another recommended video for
msnbc
i'm not seeing too many other news
stations recommended i see another one
from msnbc
notre dame faculty sign open letter
urging judge bear
two okay i see one from cnn i see a
c-span i see another msnbc
boy surprises childhood best friend
dressed as a fedex driver that could be
a little bit terrifying
okay so for the most part it was a lot
of msnbc
no fox news outlets some funny videos
some sports videos
and now the abc news search okay so
let's see how the home page looks after
watching this full video
i see a lot of abc news right off the
bat i do see a video for
fox news video from msnbc more abc news
cnbc one from cbs abc news again
a video from gq i'm noticing more
variety
this is interesting trump and clinton
are asked to say something nice about
each other
so this is actually bringing both sides
together
a hundred year old veteran and his
secrets to life
saving that video a video in favor of
joe biden here
a video from business insider there's a
lot of writing in content there's
a lot of variety in news stations and it
really isn't a polarizing
homepage okay so what we can see here is
that even by searching
just one video all of the
recommendations afterwards
reinforced that point of view there were
no recommendations that challenged it so
you'll likely stay
longer and continue to watch more videos
which would be in the best interest
of both the advertisers and the creators
what does that say about the algorithm
we called up ex youtube engineer
guillaume chalo
who built the artificial intelligence
that powers these algorithms
in an article that you wrote for wired
about youtube's
feedback loop you stated that you could
have predicted
that the ai would deliberately promote
harmful videos
behind some of the conspiracies that
we've seen recently
how could you have known that ahead of
time and
was it flagged so you can't detect
everything
ahead of time the idea is to try to
detect as soon as possible so you can
predict that there is going to be toxic
feedback loops how can you
see where the feedback loops are taking
place and for that you need the number
of recommendations
that video is promoted so if you see
that a video
is particularly being promoted by
youtube and it's toxic then you know
it's going to create a feedback loops
and do you think just the executives
have the best interest
at heart so people promoting
things like fake news and conspiracy
theories just wasn't thought of
you thought people would just genuinely
post truthful
videos and community with one another so
they were really focusing
on how to gain market share be like
20 30 percent more efficient every year
these few millions
people who were going to conspiracy
videos because of
uh youtube recommendations it was not a
big deal for them
next i talked to tristan harris who
studies the impact of technology on the
human mind
it's not just in technology this is
psychology
at the intersection of technology
fueled by super computers that's right
and let me give you one concrete example
of where this can show up
in a way it actually was told to me by
diom chaslow the former youtube engineer
if youtube found for example as it's
predicting which videos should it show
you over time
it's not just trying to maximize your
individual watch time
for that 30 minute session it also wants
to show you the kind of videos that tend
to keep you coming back in a long term
sense
so it's actually identifying these super
high level hyper object patterns
let's say one of them is called the
media is lying
let's say that that pattern that title
is associated with a longer like
year-long
trajectory of youtube usage because
obviously if i don't trust the media as
much
then i'm going to trust youtube a little
bit more and so that's an example where
there's no human who's picking
the media is lying as a phrase but the
computer is predicting and finding out
that this is a pattern that
works in a super big abstract scale that
for three billion humans that pattern
can actually cause
people to use youtube more in the long
run it's not a race that
humans are designed to win a pattern
like that can be incredibly dangerous
because it erodes trust
in society and in media which is exactly
what in general conspiracy theories do
and there's
a study in there in sense making that i
think only after two minutes of exposure
to a conspiracy theory
that people actually have less
pro-social attitudes and they're more
doubtful of the narratives that they've
been told
anyway there's there's many more aspects
to this story on the topic of youtube
and young we actually just spoke with
him
do you believe that youtube and social
media in general can send us down
echo chambers absolutely i mean i think
that's the entire model the issue is
that they're a bad apple farm
like the soil that they create is
actually about rewarding
the most extreme and conspiracy-minded
views that you could
create because they tend to get the most
clicks and as renee diresta our other
colleague who studies conspiracy
theories will
say if you can make a conspiracy trend
you can make it true because once it's
trending
like bite an earpiece or something like
that it can be on either side
once it's trending that the media covers
it they're endorsing the conspiracy
theory and elevating its response
if they don't cover it and they don't
talk about bite and ear piece now it's a
conspiracy that the media is not
covering
something that might be true exponential
rumors and accidental hearsay that's the
kind of thing that wins and it becomes
our information ecology i think it's 700
million hours a day people watch on
youtube
videos that have been recommended by the
algorithm
so the recommendation portion is
actually very significant
on the content that we end up seeing
right exactly so not only that
significant
but that pushes content creators to go
in the same direction of the algorithm
many content creators when they
talk about what what they want to do
they try to understand the algorithm
they try to just give what the algorithm
likes they don't try to understand what
you like they try to understand the
algorithm
finally i spoke with dr grant blank
who's more optimistic
about our online habits and i want to
reference a point in your research that
i found
really interesting you often hear people
go down
a rabbit hole for example on youtube and
they come up believing that the world is
flat for example
but according to your research if
somebody goes on social media
and ends up changing their mind they're
not in an echo chamber despite the
perception that somebody goes down this
rabbit hole and has now fallen
victim to these theories because they've
changed their mind
that actually proves they're not in an
echo chamber i'm not too worried
about the situation that you described
of people going down these
youtube rabbit holes people acquire
information in a broad environment
in broad ways they also change their
mind fairly often about a lot of topics
not every topic but about many topics
yeah that we're a bit more
malleable than than we think we are
right and valuable almost gives the
idea that you already had an opinion
it's in most cases people didn't have an
opinion beforehand
they only have a vague sense of what's
going on and then they encounter a more
detailed argument somewhere
and that convinces them that the real
situation is different from whatever
they thought
some tech executives would say what we
see on social media is actually just a
reflection
of what was always happening and social
media is just shining a mirror on it
do you think that's true or do you think
it's fueling it i think it's true in
this sense
it used to be reasonable for you would
go to a bar
and complain to your friends about stuff
you read or you saw
on television and it couldn't go any
further than that because you had no way
to reach a broader audience
what has happened with the internet and
the technologies of social media
is all of a sudden you can complain to
everybody
and so the things that once were kept in
small circles
are now visible to the entire world and
so
these sort of conspiracy theories and
hatred of different groups of people and
things like that which would normally
not be expressed
loudly in the public square are now
being expressed loudly
on twitter and facebook and other places
and so what has happened is that
technology has amplified
all these voices and so that they're no
longer
talking in private environments but
they're now talking in public
one of your criticisms of
youtube is the secrecy of the algorithm
and you believe that if there was more
transparency
about how the youtube algorithm works
people would have a bit more control
and we wouldn't see such massive
problems as we do today
yeah so what i want is not youtube to
give the source code of their algorithm
that's their secret source
what i want is that we have an idea of
the impact
of youtube's algorithm what is it
showing our kids right now
i want moms to be able to know what the
youtube algorithm is showing to their
kids
i want scientists to know what type of
science youtube is
is showing is it promoting a fake
science is it promoting
things that have been researched and
proved that that's important to know
so while it seems like these algorithms
are built to reinforce our likes and our
interests
how we seek out information can give us
some control
these algorithms are powerful and
impressionable
but they're not the entire story by
being aware of how they work
and being intentional and finding
information we can get back some control
[Music]